foreign
a dramatic scene in Northern Utah when a
heavily armed suspect dies during a
police shootout all this after he drove
12 hours shot and killed his brother and
set his house on fire
[Music]
I
the deadly shooting happened on April
27th in North Ogden Utah officials there
say 66-year-old Jeffrey Roberts drove
from Long Beach California to the home
of his brother Scott Roberts ring
doorbell video captures Jeffrey Roberts
approaching his brother's front door
at first the conversation seems
relatively normal hey what's up what are
you doing
she's not here where's she at Missouri
what is she doing there well she's
living with lorinda's mom who's taking
care of her really sure
well
how long has she been there
[Music]
for about a year but suddenly Roberts
reaches for his pocket after that he
opens fire
really
[Music]
hearing the gunshots nearby neighbors
call 9-1-1 it was next door and it
sounded like gunshots but
I'm not sure about that but the caller
reports that an unknown male is in his
neighborhood and there was a guy that
walked out of the house but
I couldn't tell like I said it was
pretty loud but it found it was it a
male or
a male
in a Brown Band
do you know if that male lives there or
no
no I've never seen the band but it looks
like it's a work van so I don't know
that's what I'm saying now I'm
questioning myself but
it sounded like gunshot
police arrive on the scene ring video
captures Roberts going in and out of the
house he appears to be talking on the
phone during this time
at one point Roberts is caught on video
with a weapon in his hand investigators
later confirmed Roberts was armed with a
nine millimeter handgun a 12 gauge
shotgun 23 fully loaded handgun
magazines and 150 shotgun shells
Roberts can also be heard referencing
his bank account
give it to Julie
gang it's my turn
[Music]
oh look at my garage
during this time investigators say
Roberts used road flares to start his
brother's house on fire as police arrive
on the scene Roberts begins firing as
they return fire the incident is caught
on ring video
[Music]
three officers opened fire on the scene
but only one activated their body camera
in time this is video of the officers
arriving on the scene
Jeffrey Roberts was shot and killed as
gunfire was exchanged after that
officers approach working to secure the
scene stand by stand by
I don't see his gun
s on the floor guns on the floor
he's down headshot window
[Music]
meanwhile First Responders noticed the
growing Flames inside the home they
[Music]
I don't think we can go inside with this
smoke
cover me
who's covering I got oh I got you we got
you
[Music]
I
police later confirmed Roberts shot both
his brother Scott Roberts and his
sister-in-law Jody Roberts Scott was
killed while Jody is currently
recovering at the hospital
right now the shooting is still under
investigation once complete the final
report will be sent to the Weber County
Attorney's Office reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie